hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the vhs olympiads 2022 it's um zambia
vs norway the game that we are starting
with and on board one we have uh gilan
valia versus magnus carlsen and
gilenwalia is an international master
and usually magnus would probably dodge
a game with an opponent so lower rated
than him as uh uh valia here is
over 450 rating points lower rated than
magnus carlsen and this magnus has set a
goal to himself to
breach that 2900 barrier it is a very
very dangerous to play against someone
uh so much lower rated as even a draw
would [ __ ] his rating you know
substantially and a loss well we don't
even want to talk about that uh but um
valia is is an incredibly strong player
even though okay he's an international
master but even 10 years ago in
the 2012 olympiad he scored a seven out
of nine and already next year he
qualified for defeated world cup so
magnus will have to play this very
seriously if he is the well to win on
demand but it seems that he really wants
to help uh norway do as as best as
possible here in this olympiad so let's
uh see what happened in this game as
it's quite an interesting one features a
very nice uh
uh variation of the names of indian well
basically arago is in transposed into
nimzo indian uh so avalia has the white
piece and he opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 c for e6 knight to c3 d5 we
have knight to s or d5 knight to f3 and
bishop to be for the ragosan defenses on
the board we have e3 and magnus castles
uh transposing into uh the names of
indian a3 bishop captures b captures and
pawn to c5 now so this is all been
played before nothing new here bishop to
d3 in the now magnus forces the bishop
to waste tempo d captures on c4 bishop
captures and queen to c7 now putting
pressure on the bishop if this happens
you will not be able to capture back as
the bishop will be hanging so here uh
there are many games that reach this
exact same position interestingly magnus
had this position with both white and
black against um a very strong
opposition he defeated the dingler in
here uh from this exact same position
with the black pieces and he lost to
anand
again with this exact same position on
the board where anand had the black
pieces and usually bishop to a2 and
bishop to e2 are the go-to moves here
however
uh here we have knight to d2 and it is a
an incredibly incredibly rare move okay
now the bishop is defended but um uh
well
it it's just a very rare move so let's
see how magnus uh deals with this he
just continues developing knights to c6
and now there is a game where a4 was
played but here we have castles uh and
it is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game uh so here magnus
goes rook to d8 uh makes sense you want
to put pressure on that d file and the
queen is still on d1 uh f4 uh grabbing
hold of the of the e5 square and then
now comes knight to d5 by magnus and
this is the start of a very very tricky
line uh you could also go for something
like knight a5 just go after this bishop
and once the bishop moves as it does
belong on a2 then you play b5 a6 bishop
b7 rook c8 and so on uh but magnus goes
for this um a very tricky knight to d5
move now he's attacking the c3 pawn but
also the e3 pawn as the bishop is
blocked by the knight and while you
could defend this with simply playing
knight to the e4 and now both of the
pawns are defended here we have bishop
cactus and d5 giving up the slight
square bishop and this um uh will be uh
quite troublesome for white as you'll
see he captures on the e5 and now queen
to h5
uh launching the queen into the attack
now hoping to get knight f3 knights to
g5 and put some pressure on
carlson's king also maybe a nice rook
lift can it can happen uh we'll see so
see capture sunday four magnus trades
off a pair of pawns in the center see
captures on d4 and now knight the e7 uh
we have knight to f3 and now bishop to
f5 now the knight can come or rather the
bishop can come to e4 and you will put
um incredible pressure here on the white
king so bishop d2 and now pawn to f6 now
controlling the knight and really making
it impossible for white to create any
sort of an attack here and now after
knight to h4 attacking the bishop just
bishop to e4 and here
if you if you look at the position you
can really see the difference in the
power of um
at the bishops it's a uh it's a
position where we have bishops of
opposite color magnus has a light square
bishop valia has a dark square bishop
and this bishop is just doing such a
great job attacking and defending and
this bishop
on the same color as walia spawns here
is not doing all that much so here he
wants to trade it off for this knight
with bishop to b4 and bishop captures on
e7 so f5 now uh and uh rook a to c8
developing that
rook we have rook uh sorry bishop to be
for now going after the knight and uh
magnus even forces this pawn to a5 with
bishop captures an e7 queen captures
into now rook to f4 uh getting the rook
into the attack but now magnus does the
same rook the c3 attacks the e3 pawn it
is undefended so rook to e1 and now
queen captures an a3 end and now magnus
is not only up upon but he still has
incredible pressure here on the e3 pawn
and it's very very difficult to
[Music]
defend this pawn you can't go rook f3
you can bring the knight into the game
uh if you try to defend with the queen
let's say queen to e2 we just play rook
c2 and now look at this very very
unpleasant stuff uh for example queen to
f1 even bishop d3 you start harassing
that queen if queen f3 you're gonna play
rook c1 where white is unable to trade
if you trade it's game over now you
can't play a queen c queen f1 because
the bishop covers that and next move
you're just gonna play queen to a1 and
and win the game so yeah that's out of
the question so here rook the g for his
played uh and now magnus just plays rook
to c1 this is a um a very interesting
idea as he's kind of saying okay
if you capture my uh pawn on e3 then i
can play rook to f1 uh maybe i'm still
in the game you you haven't checkmated
me maybe i'm still attacking you know
who knows what might happen however
magnus plays rook to c1 and now there
really isn't all that much you can do uh
rook captures and c1 is played but now
magnus doesn't capture back he forces a
checkmate as of course so you guys can
see that it's a mating two without even
pausing the video uh
queen captures an e3 check was played
and now of course if kinked h1 then this
is just checkmate so in the game king
the f1 was played and here magnus
delivered bishop the d3 checkmate and of
course he was in this position on move
26 that the game ended by uh guillen
valja being checkmated by magnus carlsen
so really a wild game in the nimzo
indian only 26 moves uh and um it's hard
to say you know uh white never really
uh did any any sort of a serious blunder
but uh his position uh was just a much
much worse um well as soon as uh you
know
as soon as you check out the carson's
bishop here on e4 in valya's bishop here
on d2 you can see that only magnus will
be the one pushing this for a win and
there there is no question about this so
uh there were a couple of moves that
valia could have done better uh to
fight against this variation of the
nimso indian but that's why of course
the game ended in 26 moves but other
than that it was a it was a very good
game
uh so yeah very nicely done uh you know
uh it's been a while since we've seen uh
this good of a light square bishop in
the nimso indian uh really really a
spectacular piece and uh well like i
said just just by looking at it you know
that white did something wrong to allow
something like this
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very nicely done winning
on board one for for norway and as far
as his rating goes i think he maybe wins
like one rating point for this victory
but maybe maybe even less than that who
i think it's maybe it's one
uh so yeah and uh i would like to thank
david kimura is mundalden uh jacob
tobias derek king and felix dafoe for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad
until it finishes uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day